[Music]
okay so
sometimes
you guys know this who's married
me
i am not quite yeah
unless you tell me i shouldn't wait
you're engaged engaged almost there wait
when's the wedding man
[ __ ] until crypto hits i don't know
to be honest like this is a it's a lot
of people got married bear market news
i got married 20 20. but why buy
anything else
yeah it was great
you got that many people yeah
uh so
sometimes as married men
i'm sure you can vouch for this too you
know some chicks
your chick could be a big old c
craze you have to be married tonight
all right
well
yeah
uh so a man that's a big old like big
old cool cat cool
cat okay
[Laughter]
and a man was driven
so insane by his wife being such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] comeback
a cb
that he built
uh because she's the [ __ ] about the
views
in their in their house
she's like
it's all [ __ ] same [ __ ]
it's all [ __ ] same god damn [ __ ] i
bought like a tree or something yeah
yeah
just like the same she's mad at the the
angles what's the angle she's like same
[ __ ] [ __ ] every time i look at the
wedding get your bread up then [ __ ] well
easy fix
so guess what this cat does she's not
even good at cousin he kills the same
old [ __ ] he puts his [ __ ] house
on rotating stilts
oh [ __ ]
wait that's [ __ ] only a woman who
drove a man [ __ ] insane like a
chinese dinner table
it's a lazy susie bro susan
dude
it's like literally the [ __ ] wizard
of oz house but it's on the ground you
know what he should have done was
divorce her that's what he should have
done that's true
no this is bad but this is kind of cool
it's for us for content can you imagine
though you wake up and then you just see
i don't know
this slow moving it's like that [ __ ]
rotating hotel at the lax and [ __ ] you
know what it wouldn't have been easier
to put like
out the window dude wouldn't it be
better to [ __ ] put up lcd screens and
have them change screensavers but they
don't look that rich though man that
looks like a box for a like a house you
think this was less expensive than a
couple others i mean it's just on cinder
blocks got divorced i would have been
listening wait they can't just be on
center blocks it's got to it's got to
turn bro how did they even pick that
thing up yeah exactly
innovative dude this [ __ ] was
driven mad what does it look like inside
okay so this is the gear this is one of
the gears that moves the house on this
big [ __ ] chain i already can say that
that's pretty sweet though he loves her
so much that he made things work he does
love her dude but if your wife is
complaining about that dude she's
probably gonna find something else to
complain about you might think it came
in hanum dude complainers will
consistently complain about something
else yeah you know you think it came in
too fast yeah
yeah she's like your dick's too small
build a machine for that
[ __ ]
the invention of the dark knight
you think i would have made our house
bigger if i don't do that
no so um so
he basically says
i did it with time will and knowledge
and then his wife says
i do not wish to comment on the new
house oh
she didn't like it
oh my god that's what i'm saying bro
he's he married the wrong person that's
all it is exactly he just made the wrong
person she she was complaining because
she wanted something else and he got the
loophole and she hates the fact that
he's right yeah yeah dude the house can
make a full circle in 24 hours when it's
at slowest speed whoa so it's like it's
just also it's like actually enjoyable
you're like a little bit more
like that
you're cool you're nice cause you want
to see the house that's like [ __ ]
fast and [ __ ] check this out well at its
fastest speed it can make a full circle
in under a second so you know he should
do
he should just step out the house like
this [ __ ]
wait turn it up wait like they're up
against the wall
it's like they think of the
he's walking on the walls y'all grab a
troll because he built it with a jet
engine he didn't know until he first
turned it on
a jet engine he turned it on
like to the very teen
tomcat
yeah dude to the very highest setting
wait how can this brilliant man not know
where is he from where does he live what
does he do
he's like an engineering farmer i saw
some greenhouses there yeah
oh my god so this is in bosnia and yeah
he says once i turned it on
i had no
[ __ ] idea what was about to happen me
and my wife were jettisoned against the
wall
and i couldn't reach the lever
for 48 hours [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] lion no way
you're a [ __ ] liar i swear on my
sister's ass oh your sister's ass she's
already seen scissors that's crazy he
swears by it no he's no the it makes a
full circle at its fastest speed in 22
seconds that's [ __ ] crazy that's
[ __ ] that's the 22 seconds
this [ __ ] said less than one second
can you imagine the hell ride
that's that's [ __ ] herself that's
like the walls just fly
and his wife's a baby
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god my wife's a pain i got a
[ __ ] baby that's just a blender dude
i'm gonna [ __ ] up i got a [ __ ] baby
that's his first thought that's his
first call he's like how am i gonna [ __ ]
that's shocked that's trauma he doesn't
know what's happening why didn't he get
younger yeah
he doesn't know he's not he's the person
he's like
oh [ __ ]
he's a time paradise
oh [ __ ]
i want to see that house on full spin
turns around his wife's a baby
this is the avengers this is how the
avengers happen this is how they go back
to save the world and [ __ ] kill
thanos they're like hey i heard nambazio
there's a huge house that just [ __ ]
spins in less than a second dude's wife
became a baby should work
by the way i'm ant-man
holy [ __ ]
do they have video of the house spinning
they don't man i wish i looked for it i
don't believe it yeah videoer doesn't
exist
that'll be pretty funny though i just
made this article
he typed it up on his blog
he's like this doesn't rotate at all
these are just cinder blocks
was the motive real though yeah yeah
yeah so his so his life was complaining
wish for a more diversified view for
their family home they probably just
wanted to move
that's what i'm saying that's what she
wanted or she wanted a garden let me
quote i got tired of her complaints and
frequent refurbishing of our family
house so i said i'll build you a
rotating house so you can spin it as you
wish and i picture joe saying this
like oh i'll [ __ ] build you a
rotating house you'll see
like that kind of energy because
whenever you're like this if this is
just like
when it says i got tired of her
complaints that's not red like
someone who's going through a
frustrating situation would say
i got too tired of her complaints over
complaining he probably spent so much
time under the house doing this stuff so
he got time away from his wife and he
was like loving it right he was i need
separation
wait there is a video
it just wasn't moving that fast they did
this they just need to get out of bosnia
oh my god
all your furniture is going on it's fed
up it's sped up the [ __ ] do you see
this in the clouds oh
but still man that's cool
that's a good airbnb yo that's [ __ ]
cool so then his wife won't [ __ ]
comment on the article his wife sucks
complaining ass [ __ ] this guy is a
[ __ ] genius dude oh my god
that little kid [ __ ] jump in the back
that's so cute honestly that's sick
they're clapping they love it dude
that's [ __ ] that's actually oh my god
that's genius you know sometimes like
the sun comes in at a weird angle
you could just rotate that rotate the
house now
he's got his little grandkids and [ __ ]
that's crazy man you're bosnian
i would build your rotating house so you
can spin it as you wish even the
entrance itself so if you want to see
unwanted guests coming to the entrance
on the other side as they do it and he
goes to
crane coach another strong one that you
dropped out because you
i don't know what the [ __ ]
a couple of my my good buddies are boss
names and when they pick up the phone
they go mallium they say that they go
malium they're bosnian yeah that means
hello or something that's so weird to
look at that's [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
weird bro wow
i i do also think that it is a little
bit funny like how much work actually
had to go into that guy like doing that
how do you lift that [ __ ] house put
it on a on a hand crank
on like a on a car jack oh it carjacked
it
from four angles that's what he said
no you don't this isn't bossy and i
don't know exactly what you said but
it's the translation
you put you put a balloon underneath
anybody
it was an air mattress you put on her
and it was a series of balloons
[Laughter]
that is some creative [ __ ] though
i bet it's pretty calming to see that
slowly rotate yeah and spin it as fast
as possible
what happened i wanna i wanna believe he
made a gravatron in his house though
dude those grandkids look like they're
having the time of their lives dude i
wish i had a house like please read this
part his wife did not wish to comment on
the news
this man does something that incredible
can you even believe that
she better give him [ __ ] head
she's better than rotating head bro
she better [ __ ] move her her her body
on an axis
like he should lie down in the center of
the house yep right and then she's
moving and then she's moving the other
direction yeah so he's getting full
torque helicopter yeah full tour and
she's just like this
at 22 seconds of [ __ ] rotation that's
the least that's the least she's on
she's doing this it's spinning so fast
she turns into a baby no her hands are
her hands and feet are on roller skates
while she's
like yeah while the thing is just
spinning underneath the bottom right
he's sitting on the floor
i have a stomach ache now
this is ridiculous i got bosnian skates
and there's like 400 cameras in a circle
so you get every single angle oh my god
just stop motion that [ __ ] lit stop
motion
[Music]